sabine what's going on we're being
raided it's a bloodbath
a protocol is to wipe everything
including badly i need him for the
transmitter i know but if they get him
they get everything names ops locations
okay i'll do it the old-fashioned way
wipe him yes wipe me do it sabine and
get the hell out of there [__]
[Applause]
okay
bagley's down
you're on your own
dalton if this goes
it won't
i'll see you at the rally point
i promise good luck
headings
what the hell
foreign
that hurt you more than it hurt me
[Music]
do us a favor and keep it quiet dalton
if they don't shoot me i won't shoot
them how's that
[Music]
i definitely
they've got loads of dead set gear down
here and why'd you suppose that is what
how did they get their hands on it i
don't know
well someone wants to make it look like
deadset was here [__]
you need to proceed with extreme caution
dalton
who are these men in black anyway
nothing identifying i suspect that's by
design
oh [__] me
the entire place is rigged to blow jesus
those canisters
badly is that rdx nitrogen enough to
level parliament can you locate a
detonator badly not exactly but there's
a device streaming a [__] load of
encrypted data from the floor above you
yeah that fits the bill on my way
bagley is that not the detonator no but
it's a transmitter sending a signal to a
device on the floor above us safe to
assume that would be the detonator we're
looking for
staged that set propaganda all around
the bombs
these pricks are going to blow up
parliament and hang it on us not if you
get to that detonator first
so
right in the house of commons
whoever these men in black are they've
got bollocks to set up in the center of
government
put me anywhere
update let's just say i'm both impressed
and annoyed by how sophisticated this
anti-tamper security is it's still
working
badly tell me you're close i'm through
security now wading through terabytes of
decoy code looking for the destination
sequence
ah
problem dalton i need your physical
appendages now
you